in related news president biden is
urging congress to quickly approve his
more than 33 billion request for new aid
to help ukraine fight russia the war is
entering its third month in a related
development a marine veteran was killed
fighting alongside ukrainian forces
according to his family deborah alfarone
is at the white house with the latest
debra good morning
good morning dana from the white house
to the pentagon and now to a home in
tennessee a former u.s marine and young
father is believed to be the first
american killed while fighting in
ukraine
this is 22 year old u.s marine veteran
willie joseph cancel his family says he
was killed while fighting along with
international forces in ukraine
cancel leaves behind a wife and very
young son our hearts go out to his
family
and loved ones
a journalist with u.s funded radio free
europe seen in this recent selfie video
was killed by airstrikes while she was
in her apartment in ukraine another
family grieving
these images of suspected war crimes in
bucha haven't faded from memory the
usually composed pentagon spokesperson
john kirby was visibly emotional friday
it's hard to look
at what he's doing in ukraine what his
forces are doing in ukraine and think
that any
um
ethical
moral individual could justify that it's
difficult
to look at the
sorry
with no end in sight the war also has a
price tag the cost of this fight
is not cheap president biden now pushing
congress to pass an additional 33
billion dollars in aid to ukraine that's
on top of the more than 13 and a half
billion already approved caving to
aggression is going to be more costly if
we allow it to happen
and the latest request for money
underscores the biden administration's
belief that this war could go on for
months if not longer michelle
koster endless deborah thank you